Prof: So good morning.
Today we're going to be talking
about opera, particularly opera
of the nineteenth century.
This is actually the third
opera that we have engaged in
our course, and it occurs to me
that I should ask you the names
of the other two.
Can you remember any of the
other operas that we looked at,
albeit briefly,
in this class?
Thaddeus.
Student: Don
Giovanni.
Prof: Don
Giovanni,
by Mozart.
That was the one we had a run
at acting out particular scenes
of.
We enjoyed it.
And what was the other one,
an earlier one that we heard at
least an aria out of?
Is it Leah? Leah, please.
Student: Dido and
Aeneas.
Prof: Dido and
Aeneas of Henry Purcell,
taking us back into the
seventeenth century.
So we had a seventeenth-century
opera, an eighteenth-century
opera.
Now we come to a
nineteenth-century opera.
Nineteenth-century opera,
as you may know if you've
peeked there in chapters
twenty-six,
twenty-seven,
and twenty-eight of your
textbook,
concerns two figures in
particular: one,
Richard Wagner and the other,
Giuseppe Verdi.
Now we've had some music of
Wagner before.
What was the big aria that we
dealt with out of his opera
Tristan?
Remember that?
What was that?
It had an interesting name.
Thaddeus again.
Student: The
Liebestod.
Prof: The
Liebestod--the
Liebestod of Richard
Wagner.
But we've had some Wagner here
in our course.
We've had no Verdi and I think
it's--
it is probably wiser to focus
on Verdi because Verdi in a way
is much more representative of
nineteenth-century opera
generally than is Wagner.
Wagner is a very special kind
of thing that gets put on only
in--
usually only in Wagner
festivals, whereas Verdi,
in an odd way--Verdi and Mozart
and Puccini--
are sort of the staples of most
opera companies around the
world.
Last night I went online just
to see what was happening with
Italian opera--Verdi,
and particularly La
Traviata.
And immediately,
of course, the first thing you
get on any kind of Google search
is somebody trying to sell you
tickets to something.
But I was just interested at
how many opera houses around the
world you could buy tickets for
La Traviata tonight,
tomorrow night,
or the next night.
And it turns out that there are
five opera houses in the United
States playing La
Traviata Thursday evening--
one of them at the Metropolitan
Opera.
So this gives you a sense of
hey, this is really popular;
this is what opera companies
are really working with.
So we're going to focus on
Giuseppe Verdi here and
particularly La Traviata.
Verdi is an interesting case.
We've dealt with lots of
musical prodigies,
such as Mozart,
and in an odd way,
Verdi at the beginning of his
career was an abject musical
failure.
He tried to get into--he
applied for admission to the
Conservatory of Milan and was
rejected.
He tried to get a job as the
director of music at his small
farming community of Busetto in
northern Italy near Parma and
was turned down for that job.
So he got a job as the town
bandmaster,
ultimately, but he was--he
persevered and he continued to
write operas,
and then eventually he got one
performed at La Scala.
Now, La Scala is the main opera
house in Milan.
So that was successful.
And on the basis of that
success, then impresarios--
producers around the
world--contacted Verdi and tried
to convince him to write operas
for their theaters.
And he did, and eventually his
career spread even to North
America and South America.
So let's take a moment and look
at the operas that Verdi
composed.
You have a list over there.
Put Nabucco on because
that's the one that launched his
career, really,
in Milan in eighteen forty-two.
Then we have a series there in
the middle: Rigoletto,
Il Trovatore,
La Traviata.
These are sometimes called his
more "domestic"
type of opera subjects--rather
than historical ones.
Then we move on to later works.
You can see Don Carlos
there, another historical one;
Aida,
for the opening of the Suez
Canal;
Otello;
and Falstaff based off
of the--I guess "The Merry
Wives of Windsor."
So you can see a couple of
points here: one,
that Verdi lived a long time
and was active as a creative
artist for a very long period of
time.
Any other artist has a longer
productive career than Verdi?
There is one painter working in
the twentieth century.
Think about it a minute.
Picasso, yeah,
from about 1905 until really
the time of his death in the
early 1970s I guess.
So he was productive,
in the case of Verdi,
for five or six decades there.
And notice also the importance
of Shakespeare here,
lots of Shakespearian setting.
Shakespeare was the dominant
literary figure of the
nineteenth century.
So let's turn our attention now
to La Traviata.
It's based on a play of
Alexander Dumas,
Alexandre Dumas--fils
actually.
Père happens to
be on the cover of our textbook.
The son wrote a play called
"The Lady of the
Camellias."
Camellia is a white flower.
And the play was simply staging
a true-life story involving this
playwright,
Alexandre Dumas the younger,
and his love affair with a
young lady named Marie du
Plessis.
You have a picture of Marie
Duplessis in page--on page 302
of your textbook.
She was a girl from the country
who,
by a liberal allocation of
charm, and an even more generous
distribution of her virtue
managed to sleep her way to the
top of Parisian society at that
time.
I was trying to think this
morning.
I don't know very much about
popular culture,
but who would be like that
today?
I don't know.
I--Paris Hilton,
people like--I don't know,
but she was kind of the tabloid
figure of the nineteenth century
so much so that I was struck--
I came upon this recently.
Charles Dickens--and you don't
think of Dickens and Paris
Hilton in the same sentence
normally but Charles Dickens in
faraway England at this time
noticed that when Marie
Duplessis died in Paris--
and she died at the shockingly
young age of twenty-three--
when she died,
Dickens said the following:
"You would have thought
her passing was a question of
life and death or the death of a
hero such as Joan of Arc."
So, obviously again sort of
capturing everyone's attention.
In any event,
we're going to watch La
Traviata on a video.
And that video will be on
reserve for you and you've got
some hints about that on that
flip side of your sheet.
Everybody got the sheet for
today?
It says "Opera News."
You're going to be watching a
video and you'll see there that
the scene is set in Paris about
1845,
so this is core romantic time,
a core romantic place:
Paris, 1845.
La Traviata--what does
that mean?
Well, if you break it down in
terms of its syllables you get
the following:
"La,"
feminine article I guess,
"tra,"
on the other side of,
"via" is a road,
"ta"
is a feminine thing,
so we have the woman that's
sort of fallen off the beaten
path,
or the expected road here.
She's the woman who has gone
astray.
She is a kept woman,
a courtesan,
if you will,
a sort of high-class hooker
here, and at the moment,
she is under the protection of
one Baron Douphol.
He's the bad guy in our opera,
the bad guy on our video.
The opera opens at a party.
In comes our hero.
His name is Alfredo.
So the love couple here,
the love interests:
Alfredo-Violetta.
Violetta is the woman gone
astray.
So Alfredo comes in and he
proposes a toast.
So we're going to listen to a
little bit of our first music
this morning.
I will probably be breaking up
this music and commenting more
than I normally would,
for reasons of copyright.
I needn't say more or go into
that more than that,
but I'm gonna break it up a
little bit more than I normally
would.
So let's listen to a little bit
and think about here--think of
the meter, think of the mode as
we listen to this opening
chorus.
>
Okay.
Let's just pause it here for a
second.
You have the text.
It's the opening
thing--aria--here,
Alfredo.
At the top there,
waltz and drinking song,
"Libiamo,"
let us drink,
and so on;
let's have a good time.
What about the mode and the
meter?
Basic question.
Well, if it's a waltz it's got
to be triple.
Okay.
So we have a fast triple,
>
and the mode, major or minor?
Minor?
Let's listen to some more.
>
What about that chord?
Major or minor?
So it's all in major.
So we have a happy,
joyful sort of crowd scene read
by Alfredo here.
Then he steps forward to
announce his--to profess his
love to Violetta.
He's been admiring her from
afar, and we have the first
major aria here.
You have your sheet and you can
see the arrow pointing to it,
"Un Di Felice."
And let's listen to a bit of
this now and the same question
to you: the mode and the meter
of this.
We'll listen to a little bit of
it and then we'll talk about
tempo here so let's pay
particular attention to tempo
and meter.
>
Here we go.
Can you conduct it?
Where's the beat?
>
Good.
Evgeny's got it.
Stand up and conduct for
everyone--no,
don't stand up but a nice,
big beat for--very good.
>
Okay.
All right.
So we've got a nice,
slow triple meter here and what
about the--it's mostly major but
sort of tinged a little bit with
minor.
Let's watch what happens to the
tempo now.
We're kind of one,
two, three, one,
two, three.
A little bit more.
>
Okay.
So we're going to pause it
there.
So what happened?
Well, obviously the tempo
slowed way, way down there.
And we have this term for
this--it's part and parcel of
the romantic era--
called tempo rubato,
flexibility,
more unstable tempos here,
again part of the instability
in a way and the mercurial
switches back and forth of mood
of the romantic period.
"Tempo rubato"
literally means
"robbed."
"Rubato"
means "robbed,"
"something robbed."
Well, here the tempo is robbed.
We're taking away.
We're slowing it way down here
and then it will speed back up
to catch back up,
so it's kind of like a Slinky.
Remember the Slinky you had as
a kid that you'd put on the step
and it'd go really fast and then
slow and then all over the top.
And so that's what--sort of
what tempo rubato is.
So let's listen to a little bit
more.
>
Here's a shift to minor
and the word
"mystery,"
>
more rubato there,
slowed it way down.
>
Okay.
Let's pause it here just for a
second.
Now Violetta's going to come in.
And I would ask you,
"How does Violetta's music
differ from the music of
Alfredo?"
You ought to be to think of a
couple of ways here.
Let's listen to Violetta.
>
Okay. So we'll pause it there.
So how does that music differ
from what we've just heard?
Anybody?
Jerry.
Student: It's faster.
Prof: It's faster.
All right.
Take the basics.
It's faster.
What did you sense about it?
Darker or lighter?
Probably lighter.
It's--and it's higher in range
and it's a little bit flighty
and it's more disjunct.
And this is what composers do.
They try to depict characters.
So right off the bat we have
this kind of live-for-the-moment
character, Violetta,
coming in.
She doesn't want to have
anything to do with this mystery
of love that Alfredo is
proposing here.
And this is what Verdi was good
at and this is what Mozart was
very good at.
One of the things we should
have noticed about that lovely
duet that Richard Lalli and
Lynda sang the other day,
"La Ci Darem La
Mano," was that,
as they were singing,
Mozart was writing music in
which there were rests in
between each entry of the
singers.
And then as that duet went
on--and we didn't even notice,
but it's crucial to the effect
of the duet--
as the duet went on the length
of those rests got smaller and
smaller.
And eventually they disappeared.
And what Mozart is telling us
here is that just as physical--
as sonic space is disappearing,
so too the distance between
these two individuals is
disappearing.
They're getting closer together
musically as they're getting
closer together physically.
And then it ended up with
>
right together in parallel
thirds there so Mozart brings
this music all together.
Well, watch what happens here.
Who's going to win out?
Is Violetta's light music going
to win out?
Is Alfredo going to start
singing like Violetta or is
Violetta going to start singing
like Alfredo?
Let's listen a bit more.
>
Okay.
Let's pause it right there.
So who won?
Who got his or her way?
Roger.
Student: Alfredo.
Prof: Alfredo, right.
So she came down in her range.
She shifted to a slightly
minor-tinted sound and then the
tempo of the music slowed down
so he won that contest of
musical wills there or musical
characterizations.
So we're going to listen to a
little bit more of this,
and now we want to shift our
attention over to the issue of
the relationship between the
voice and the orchestra.
And this is very different from
what happens in Wagner.
So we're listening here to a
typical setup of Verdi,
and what is the relationship of
the voice and the orchestra?
What is the orchestra doing
here?
>
Okay. Let's pause here.
What's the orchestra doing?
>
, a little sort of pizzicato
support underneath,
not much more.
Let's listen to a bit more here
and see what the orchestra is
doing.
>
Let's pause it here.
What's the orchestra doing?
Absolutely nuttin'.
It's disappearing completely.
What is this? What's going on?
Well, this is the period--the
great period--of bel
canto singing.
Literally, "bel
canto" just means
"beautiful song,"
"beautiful song
singing,"
where all of the attention is
focused on the voice.
That's what the audience is
paying to hear.
They don't care.
You almost get an amplified
guitar underneath there and play
that accompaniment so it's all
in the voices here.
And again it's very different
than the orchestrally dominated
score of Wagner.
So let's listen to the end of
this aria, voices alone.
>
Okay.
So that's the first big aria
together;
indeed it's a duet.
Now we're going on--to move on
here in La Traviata to
something called a scena.
And a scena--the Italian
word "scena"
of course is simply
"scene"
but in opera it's a little bit
more complex than that.
What we have is an amalgam of
three items.
We have an aria followed by a
recitative followed by another
aria, and that final aria is a
very fast aria.
Indeed it's something called a
cabaletta,
that we'll talk about later on.
So now we're moving on our text
sheet here to the second arrow,
where we have an aria sung by
Violetta.
She's saying to herself--she's
off by herself--"Ah,
perhaps he is the one that I
have been waiting for.
Maybe this is finally the great
true love of my life."
Let's listen to a little bit of
this.
>
All right. We'll stop there.
Obviously, this is an aria
because there's so much
attention on just producing
sound,
sliding all the way up to that
high note,
and it happens to be in a minor
key.
Then she begins to reflect
further on this and she says,
"Well, no.
This is not what I want to do.
Think about my situation here.
Here I am in Paris,
alone and abandoned."
We're going to go on to the
next arrow here down a little
bit below: "Folia,
folio, delirio e vanno e questo
povera donna"--
"Poor Lady"--
"Solo, abbandonata in
questo..."
<<quotes in
Italian>>
"What am I going to do?
Well, I'm going to enjoy
myself."
So what we have here is a
recitative, but it's a different
kind of recitative than we've
had up to this point in our
course.
Up to this point,
we've had recitative called
"simple recitative"
and this is the recitative of
the seventeenth and eighteenth
century that--
in which the particular
protagonist would be going along
and trying to relate what is
happening at that time and then
would come to the end of a
section <<plays
piano>>
, something like that,
and would be accompanied only
very lightly by a keyboard
underneath.
And that--that's kind of all
that's accompanied.
But now we move on to a bigger
kind of accompanying,
orchestrally accompanied
recitative.
It's got this fancy
Italian-sounding word,
recitativo accompagnato.
We could pronounce it that way
or just say "accompanied
recitative."
It's the same deal.
You get the full orchestra
accompanying rather than just
the keyboard.
So let's listen to a good
example of nineteenth-century
recitative but recitative that
is fully accompanied.
>
So here we are at the third
arrow, <<music
playing>>
a lot of tremolo in the strings.
>
"What am I going to
do?" "Che faro
deggio?"
>
Now this is a very joyful
setting of the word
"gioire."
>
And then the third part of our
scena begins.
Now we have the beginning of a
fast aria.
It's called a cabaletta.
It's an operatic device.
It usually appears at the end
of the scene in order to allow
the protagonist to make a strong
declaration or an emphatic
statement and then
enthusiastically exit stage left
or stage right.
It's a kind of convention to
get the protagonist off the
stage.
Let's listen to a couple of
seconds of this and we're going
to come back to this particular
cabaletta,
"Sempre Libre."
It's a famous one--virtually
every major soprano has sung
it--in which Violetta vows to
remain always free.
>
All right.
We're going to stop it there.
We will come back to that.
But of course,
Violetta doesn't remain free.
She succumbs to the advances of
Alfredo.
The two of them live blissfully
together for a while,
then quarrel,
separate.
Ultimately, they are reunited
after a period of time,
but she has developed
consumption, tuberculosis,
akin to the AIDS of the
nineteenth century,
and she dies at the end of the
opera.
We've talked about this
convention of opera before.
Remember: "It ain't over
'til the fat lady sings."
That's probably a silly remark
about opera.
In this case,
it ain't over until the thin
lady sings because on our video
we have the role of Violetta
sung by Teresa Stratas,
the very thin Teresa
Stratas--and she is a very fine
actress indeed.
That's why she was chosen for
this video production.
So that, in brief,
is the story of La
Traviata and you've got a
video of it that I ask you to
watch scenes out of.
It's directed by Franco
Zefirelli and it was a
production that he put together
in the mid 1980s and it's still
used at the Met .
Again if you go there Thursday
night,
if you can pony up the
expensive--the big bucks for the
tickets--
boy, are they expensive--you
can see this Zefirelli
production--
with different singers of
course, that are on--
than those on the video,
but it's still being produced--
all the sets and the costumes
and all,
exactly as you will see it
there in your video.
Okay.
So now what I want to do with
the rest of the session today,
having established a little bit
about Verdi and a little bit
about La Traviata,
is talk about singers'
voices--what to listen for with
regard to singers.
When we went to the Saybrook
Orchestra concert and we went to
the Jonathan Edwards makeup
concert we were engaging a
critical ear with regard to
hearing instrumental sounds,
orchestral sounds.
Well, now we want to do the
same thing <<music
playing>>
with regard to vocal sound.
So what is it that makes a good
operatic singer?
Anybody in here take--ever take
some voice lessons?
I bet you have.
Don't be bashful now.
Kristin?
Okay.
Did you ever try singing any
opera?
Okay. Oh, good for you.
Well, tell us about it.
I don't mean to put you on the
spot here.
Do you remember--what was--any
particular opera that you
remember?
Student: Gianni
Schicchi.
Prof: Gianni
Oh, how interesting.
That has that beautiful "O
Mio Babbino Caro"
that we used as an example of
melody a little bit earlier in
our course so--
by Puccini, of course.
So let's talk about this for a
minute.
What constitutes a good
operatic voice?--
which may be a little bit
different than what constitutes
a good church voice or a good
synagogue voice or a good mosque
voice on top of a minaret,
whatever it might happen to be.
We're talking opera here.
What do you need to have to
have a good operatic voice?
What would you guess?
Well, nice tone,
a nice tone,
and a tone that's even from top
to bottom.
Oftentimes you run in to
singers that have what's called
a break in their voice.
It might have one tone quality
in the lower register and then
you can hear it shift in to a
different tone quality in the
upper register.
So you--we don't want that.
We want a kind of smooth
quality from beginning to end.
Richness of tone color.
Other things.
Roger, you had your hand up.
Anything you want to add to
that?
Student: The need to
project--
Prof: Okay.
Project the voice.
That's very important.
You've got to have a powerful
voice.
You have to have a powerful
voice because if you're singing
at the Met--
this came up in my section the
other day--
are you allowed to have
microphones there?
No, not at the Metropolitan
Opera.
You have to have a natural
voice that's going to fill that
auditorium of twenty-five,
twenty-six, twenty-seven
hundred people.
If you go to a Broadway show,
are the singers amplified by
microphones there--"Phantom
of the Opera"?
Yes, they certainly are.
And we talked about that,
how that sound is picked up and
immediately sent to a mixing
board in the back and there's an
electronic engineer there
manipulating that sound.
But for opera singers--you
don't get to do that.
You have to have a powerful
voice that's going to fill the
hall and they want you to fill
the hall.
They want to fill the hall
'cause they got to sell tickets.
So they want big halls.
So you have to have a powerful
voice.
What about the quality of the
voice?
Well, the bigger the hall
oftentimes you have to generate
a vibrato.
Right?
And we've talked about that
with string players.
But what's the liability of a
vibrato?
Well, sometimes it can get so
big that it becomes
uncomfortable.
What is the pitch, please?
So we have to have a
well-focused voice.
You have to have a powerful
voice, a well-focused voice,
and so on.
So let's listen to a couple of
famous singers here in the
course of the twentieth century.
I am struck by this 'cause a
lot of my acquaintances like
this music.
I was interested this morning
that our cameraman,
Jude, said that each morning
his mother listens to Pavarotti
and Bocelli.
So here is Andrea Bocelli.
And let's listen to a little
bit of his singing.
How many of you know who this
fellow Bocelli is?
Most of you. Okay.
He's frequently on television.
So listen--a little bit of
Andrea Bocelli and we'll
focus--try to comment on his
voice.
>
Okay.
I'd better stop it there before
I get in trouble.
What do you think of that voice?
What do you think of that sound?
Would you buy that?
Is that opera?
Well, it's a little--it is kind
of an operatic voice.
Actually, he studied with
Pavarotti.
Is it as good as Pavarotti's
voice?
Well, I--we don't have all
morning to focus on this.
No, it's not as good as
Pavarotti's voice.
He goes in the upper register
and he can't hold the notes for
as long .
It's more pinched.
You feel that he's
uncomfortable there.
In terms of the style of this
music,
is--why is this not--and this
is something--
what makes this not a real
opera aria here,
different than an opera aria
right at the beginning?
It's much more rhythmic. Right?
It's got a back beat to it and
has a strong bass component and
a strong rhythmic component.
It's what I call
"pop-op"
or "op-pop,"
either way,
"popular opera,"
"opular popera,"
whatever.
There's a kind of blend between
the two so it's somewhere
between opera and pop music.
Let's go on now to talk about
the two tenors that have
dominated the twentieth century
and one of them continues to
dominate in the twenty-first
century,
Luciano Pavarotti and Placido
Domingo.
Okay.
Let's start with
Domingo--really developed as a
baritone voice,
then a second tenor,
and then pushed himself up in
to the higher range to sing
first tenor,
but not initially trained as a
first tenor.
A highly intelligent man,
a great actor,
a conductor.
It's fascinating.
Sometimes he will sing a
matinee and then in the evening
will go in to the pit to conduct
an opera,
so a really impressive
musician, but maybe not the
voice of Pavarotti.
Let's listen to the two of them
sing the same passage,
and we have this at the bottom
of your sheet here.
It's a cabaletta in
which the hero,
Alfredo, vows to wash away the
sin that has been visited on his
family.
He's going to wash away this
disgrace.
So he's going to say,
"I'm going to wash this
away" and then he's going
to exit the stage.
So let's listen to Domingo sing
this passage.
You have the text,
again, at the bottom of your
sheet.
>
Okay. No comment.
Let's go on now to listen to
Luciano Pavarotti sing the same
passage.
>
So what's the difference,
maybe two things there that are
immediately evident?
Roger.
Student: He has a
stronger voice--
Prof: He has a stronger,
more powerful voice.
I had to ask them to turn down
the volume.
It's huge and it's rich too.
Anything else there?
We were talking about--Emily,
is it?
Uh huh.
Student: Pavarotti has
stamina.
Prof: Yeah.
You heard at the end there--I
was starting to look at my watch
just as--Domingo held that note
for four seconds.
It's like a diving contest or
something.
We're going to hold up a ten or
a seven after this jump here.
But Domingo held this for four
seconds.
Pavarotti held it for eleven
seconds--just a hugely high
note.
I think it's a high C.
It's way up here.
>
I don't know.
Maybe somebody with absolute
pitch can tell us what that was,
a hugely high note,
and he just sat on this thing,
powerful, beautiful tone.
It really is--was--amazing.
Now I think through the marvels
of modern technology here--
and we may crash and burn--we
will find out--
take a look here at Pavarotti
singing what might have been his
signature aria,
"Nessun Dorma,"
out of Turandot and you
have Turandot discussed
in the exoticism chapter of your
textbook.
And the set-up here,
as Lynda cues this
particular--is that
he--"Nessun Dorma"
means no one will sleep.
He's going to go out and find
the answer to the riddle that
will allow him to be successful
in his conquest of this ice-cold
princess that he wants to make
amorous advances upon.
So here's Luciano Pavarotti
sing--This is the end of
"Nessun Dorma"
and here's Pavarotti with Zubin
Mehta conducting the New York
Phil.
And thanks to Lynda for helping
me out and getting all of these
things up and bookmarks and
queued and things.
>
Okay.
So that's the great Luciano
Pavarotti and he was great.
In terms of male voices,
I've never heard--
and I've listened to a bit of
this,
going backtracking into the
1920s, and I've never heard
anything like this in the entire
twentieth century--
but a word of caution.
You can go on YouTube here and
you'll see Pavarotti's picture
coming up with the same aria and
maybe four or five different
recordings of it.
When was Pavarotti really good
and when did he stop being
really good?
Don't buy anything of Pavarotti
after 1980..
From 'seventy eight,
'seventy-nine,
'eighty--that's the heyday of
Pavarotti's recordings and
they're spectacular.
Nobody could touch this guy.
But thereafter they really do
begin to decline and you could
do comparative--
comparisons of these various
recordings over time to watch
the decline,
and it's sort of sad,
but it's the natural process of
the aging of the voice and the
aging of the body.
So now we're going to talk
about the ladies.
We have a number of different
voice terms here,
vocal terms applying to
particular registers.
The lowest part of the female
operatic register is called the
contralto and there are some
floating around.
There used to be Maria--Maureen
Forrester.
Across the street at our School
of Music, Lili Chookasian
used to sing at the
Metropolitan Opera.
She teaches--is still teaching
at the School of Music.
I went to school with a woman
named Joyce Castle,
a contralto,
frequently singing with the
Met.
So that's the kind of low part,
the alto, if you will,
of the female voice in opera.
Then we have the mezzo-soprano,
kind of half-soprano,
mezzo,
mezzo forte:
half loud.
That's between an alto and a
soprano.
Frequently, we've had here at
Yale Frederica von Stade.
She's a good example of a
mezzo-soprano,
sneaking up in to the soprano
range.
Then we have a soprano voice
called the lyric soprano so
we're up in the high part of the
female range,
the lyric soprano,
lovely sound,
a smooth sound.
We also have a soprano called a
dramatic soprano and these are
voices like Kirsten Flagstad,
Birgit Nilsson and more
recently Jane Eaglen,
Deborah Voigt.
These are the women that sing
Wagner and sing Strauss where
you really need superhuman,
large voices with plenty of
powerful, well-focused vibrato.
And then finally we have a
voice range called the
coloratura,
the very top part of the
soprano range--
very high, tends to be light,
tends--
if it's good--tends to be well
focused.
What does a coloratura sound
like?
We don't have a visual here but
we do have the leading,
I think, coloratura today,
Natalie Dessay,
singing just a bit of something
called the coloratura soprano
just to give you a sense of what
a coloratura sounds like.
>
You get the idea,
high and light.
That's what the coloratura is
all about.
Now we're going to focus on
four sopranos singing the same
aria by way of comparison here.
And the aria in question is the
part of that scena that
we were dealing with before,
"Ah, forse lui, Folia,
Folia" and ultimately
"Sempre Libre."
The first soprano we're going
to start with is Nellie Melba.
She was an Australian soprano
and was the leading prima donna
around the turn of the twentieth
century.
So this recording--This
particular recording was made
here on our own historical sound
collection off of an old vinyl.
It goes back to ninteen oh-five.
So here's Nellie Melba singing.
It's a very interesting voice.
Tell me what you think about it.
Put two adjectives with this
voice.
>
Okay. Let's stop it right there.
What did you think?
Santana and Lynda,
you're both professional
singers.
What did you think of Nellie
Melba here?
Your head is elsewhere but any
thoughts?
Student: I love it.
But it sounds like you're
allowed to have a much smaller
of a voice--
Prof: Okay. Yes.
"I love it but it sounds
like you're allowed to have a
much smaller voice."
The Wagnerian voice hadn't
carried the whole world at this
point and we think that this is
much more typical of
nineteenth-century singing:
well focused,
right on pitch but lighter,
perhaps something closer to the
coloratura.
Now we're going to move on for
reasons of time to another video
and we're going to hear the
dominant prima donna of the
mid-twentieth century and that
was Maria Callas.
Anybody ever heard of Maria
Callas?
Okay.
>
She was something of a fashion
statement, a femme fatale
and soprano that dominated the
operatic stage in the 1950s.
Let's listen to a bit of her
singing.
Let's see if you like it.
>
Let's stop it there.
Do you like that sound?
Yes or no. How many like it?
How many don't like it?
It reminds me of the fact that
one town that in California
recently passed or a couple
years ago passed an ordinance.
To get vagrants out of this
particular shopping center,
they would pipe nothing but
Maria Callas over the public
address system.
It's a very kind of sharp,
penetrating voice and the older
she got the wider that vibrato
got,
so some people don't find that
particular--
that sound particularly
attractive.
Let's go on to--not in
chronologic order 'cause I'm
going to finish with somebody
else--
but the reigning diva of today,
Renée Fleming from
Rochester, New York.
Her mother is a public school
teacher,
was a public school voice
teacher in Rochester,
so she's just a hometown girl
from Rochester here,
but now she is the glamour
girl, the poster girl,
for all of the--all sopranos in
opera.
And I think we have a video of
the famous Renée
Fleming--
always sells out the
Met--singing this material,
and as we listen what interests
me here is her capacity to
control the voice.
Wow.
She sort of can sit that tone
out there and just spin it this
way or spin it that way,
slow it down,
make it roll faster.
It really--it may not be the
biggest.
It may not be the most--always
the richest--but boy,
it is sure the most controlled
of these sopranos that I have
seen.
>
Okay. So very impressive.
And then finally we're going to
hear from--oh,
question.
Daniel.
Student:
>
Prof: I don't know how
they do it.
I've never--I have enough
trouble standing up and singing,
but I guess you wonder about
that, how they can do that,
how they can keep that pressure
and tone and all,
reclined like that but they
always do it.
It's not unusual to see that.
And we're going to end here
with a couple of things,
Joan Sutherland,
probably the greatest soprano
of the twentieth century.
She really also reached her
peak about 1980 and she
frequently sang with Pavarotti
and on the CDs for your--
our course here,
I have chosen Pavarotti and
Sutherland singing La
Traviata because I get to
choose these particular CDs,
the recordings that go on our
CDs.
So here you're going to see a
bit of Joan Sutherland.
She wasn't particularly
distinguished as an actress but
boy, what a voice,
and what you're going to hear
here--and I'll play this very
quickly.
We've got a line that's going
>.
She's going to add a soprano
line here that goes--
jumps up an octave higher than
Verdi actually wrote it,
and if you listen to Fleming in
this aria Fleming will end here;
>
Sutherland will end
a full octave higher.
So let's listen to this woman
with a beautiful coloratura,
very well focused,
powerful in all ranges,
sort of the complete voice.
And then on the way out while
we're loading this,
we have the
"Habanera"
of Bizet on our quiz and we're
going to have an alternative
performance of Bizet's
"Habanera."
Listen to your CDs.
Let's go to our last clip.
You remember the
"Habanera"
with the <<plays
piano>>
and so on, the descending
chromatic scale,
ostinato underneath.
I found a better version of
this.
I don't know whether this is
the dumbest thing <<music
playing>>
you have ever seen;
it probably is.
Or it's really funny.
I can't tell.
>
So I don't know what kind of
soprano voice this is,
but it sure is different.
>
Okay.
So lets see if we--I--I'm still
after--Here's Sutherland.
>